[Applause]
give me one minute and i'll show you
how virtual private cloud serves as a
foundation for your network in the cloud
virtual private cloud or vpc is the
managed networking service
for your google cloud infrastructure you
can think of it as
similar to a traditional physical
network except it's virtualized within
google cloud
vpcs on google cloud have a global scope
so a single vpc can span across multiple
regions
all over the world securely without
communicating across the public internet
vpcs are shareable between google cloud
projects
or even organizations in some cases that
means
you can use a single shared vpc for your
entire organization
so that teams isolated within projects
can maintain a shared private ip space
to access
commonly used services need to expand
your network
no problem google cloud vpc lets you
increase the iep space of any subnet
without any downtime
or workload shutdown giving you the
flexibility to grow your network to meet
your needs
by default your google cloud projects
are ready to roll with a default vpc
configured with multiple subnets created
across multiple regions
you can use these subnets or you can
create your own allowing you to
configure the number of subnets their
corresponding regions
and their ip address ranges do you have
existing infrastructure outside of
google cloud that you want to connect to
your vpc
there are multiple ways to create a
hybrid networking solution using
dedicated or partner interconnect
cloud vpn or even via partner supported
sd-wan connections
keep things on your network safe and
secure with packet mirroring
this allows you to mirror all traffic
between your compute instances
in your vpc so that you can inspect and
analyze it for application performance
issues
or to detect threats and anomalies so
next time you're looking into how you
can build your network in the cloud take
a minute to check out
google cloud vpcs or private managed
network in the cloud
to learn more check out cloud.google.com
vpc